el panorama de kobe 19 en brasil tiene
todos los elementos del lado positivo se
presentó en público la wood ambac la
vacuna brasileña contra el coronavirus
desarrollada en el instituto butantán el
gobernador de sao paulo joao doria busca
empezar los ensayos de fase 1 y 2 con la
primera solución brasileña
es un orgullo para todos nosotros una
dosis de esperanza para los brasileños y
una forma de honrar a las personas que
se han ido atentos que si form
un optimismo que se produce en el peor
momento de la pandemia con más de
300.000 muertos la saturación es total y
en la misma sao paulo ya se están
realizando entierros nocturnos una
situación de colapso contra la que cargó
con dureza el expresidente lula da silva
el martes murieron en brasil tres mil
158 personas a consecuencia del cobe 19
es el mayor genocidio de nuestra
historia
estas acusaciones coinciden en pleno
cambio de discurso del gobierno de
bolsonaro incluso el vicepresidente de
hamilton mural reconoció la gravedad del
momento
vamos a enfrentarnos a lo que está ahí e
intentar de todas las maneras posibles
disminuir la cantidad de contagios y
obviamente el número de muertos que
superó el límite del sentido común y por
último además de vacunas y de colapsos
en río de janeiro hubo protestas contra
las restricciones por el cob y 19 por
sus efectos económicos y la
imposibilidad para muchos de poder
trabajar